alors c'était bien avant johnny sylvie
et 10 étaient à l'époque de l'indochine
ndian fouet l'était pas et puis un
chanteur qui était arrivé il a été le
premier à dire ouais comme les
américains disaient hier il a été le
premier à casser sa voix sur scène le
premier pour qui on a cassé des
fauteuils à l'olympia c'est lui qui a
inventé salut les copains c'est lui qui
a inventé mademoiselle achetant enfin
âge tendre et tête de bois
trente ans plus tard il est toujours là
plus que jamais voici gilbert bécaud
bonjour salut les copains ça va bien ça
va très bien c'est la porn ouais je te
remercie d'être venu à ce coup passé mon
plaisir je la vois chaque fois que je
peux merci je voyage beaucoup mais je
vois de temps en temps j'aime bien c'est
bien on est content que tu sois là aussi
alors gilbert orné à l'âge tous les deux
où on passe des check-up
enfin moi à toi pas moi et celui-ci
non moi je veux pas aux cigarettes au
whisky voilà on va en parler un jeu de
faire une petite interview tchèque
on va passer un peu tout en revue quoi
alors commençons par l'amour oui comment
réussit l'exploit de faire vivre deux
épouses sous le même toit
non elles sont pas deux épouses en même
temps et essai suivi à face à va très
bien quoi ça se passe bien c'est le rêve
de tout homme normalement constitué
d'avoir deux femmes au lieu d'une non on
est civilisés c'est tout ouais alors la
santé maintenant tu fumes un peu oui tu
bois un peu ouais un étrange les angles
oui mais sans le moindre enjeu je pense
que des miettes et ont tout piqué ce qui
lie type alt calmer un peu non contents
ils me dirent est comme ça tu vas très
bien ne bouge pas sur tout nouveau
change rien ouais donc tu continues oui
on ne change pas la tactique gagnante
non la politique quand il a écrit une
chanson qui est restée dans toutes les
mémoires c'est tu le regretteras on sait
pas de temps dans toutes les mémoires
parce qu'à l'époque où j'ai écrit la
chanson d'ailleurs de toute façon je
n'avais pas écrit d'une façon politique
avait toujours pris la chanson de
travers et puis ce général de gold mais
c'était pas politique du tout tu me
diras si difficile et que sur le général
de gaulle c'est pas politique bien
pourtant ce n était pas politique
j'aurais pu écrire sur sur churchill son
retour et faire enfin un homme important
et de gaulle avait accueilli comment la
chanson moi je connaissais bien le
général de gaulle
on en avait pas vrai un bon pas bon et
tu fais la même chose pour mitterrand en
jeu ne se passe et pas si ça dépend
beaucoup plus de mitterrand que moi s'il
devient aussi grande de gaulle je pense
que puis serait peut-être possible on
verra alors dernière question du
check-up le look de look
tu es célèbre pour ta cravate à pois et
et costumes et puis d'un seul coup tu
viens sans cravate à pois il son costume
aussi à l'après midi la cravate c'est
pour la scène
d'accord pour les émissions de variétés
un adversaire alors gilbert